lo que quiero que hagamos en este vídeo
es que nos familiaricemos con una de las
moléculas más importantes de biología
que se llama glucosa o también es
conocida como dextrosa y el término
dextrosa proviene del hecho de que la
glucosa la forma de la glucosa
típicamente encontrada en la naturaleza
si la ponemos en una solución de agua
polariza la luz hacia la derecha
walker y esta parte de aquí dextro
significa a derecha mientras que este
término glucosa significa dulce no crazy
le preguntas a algún amigo griego que
tengas que te digan cómo se dice dulce
te va a decir algo así como ricos no lo
estoy pronunciando bien pero eso es lo
que significa ok de aquí es de donde
viene la palabra y la glucosa es súper
importante porque esta es la forma en la
que se almacena y se transporta la
energía en los sistemas biológicos
también cuando coloquialmente alguien
habla acerca de los niveles de azúcar en
la sangre en realidad está hablando de
la concentración de glucosa en la sangre
que cuando alguien habla acerca del
azúcar en la sangre en realidad están
hablando de la concentración de glucosa
en la sangre y además todo eso del
proceso de fotosíntesis de lo que se
trata es de que las plantas aprovechan
la energía del sol y la almacenan en
forma de glucosa y también cuando
estamos hablando acerca de la
respiración celular en nuestras células
de lo que se trata es de tomar glucosa y
utilizarla para formar atp que es como
la moneda molecular con la cual
transferimos energía dentro de nuestro
cuerpo porque hay entonces la glucosa es
una molécula muy importante
y pues podemos empezar a formar cadenas
de glucosa para formar glucógeno o
también formar almidón y eso junto con
otro tipo muy simple de azúcar las
puedes usar para formar el azúcar que
nos comemos normalmente aunque hay el
azúcar que encuentras en tu mesa pero
incluso la glucosa así solita también es
dulce bueno pues ahora vamos a
familiarizarnos con ella como una
molécula
que hoy tenemos por aquí la glucosa la
tenemos aquí dibujada como una cadena de
abierta y podemos ver que tiene 1 2 3 4
5 6 carbonos así es que en su fórmula
química tenemos por aquí
sub 6 y ahora cuántos hidrógenos tiene
pues tiene 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
hidrógenos 12 hidrógenos c 6 h 12 y
finalmente cuántos oxígenos tenemos pues
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 oxígenos y aquí lo
que tenemos entonces son 6 carbonos y
luego por cada átomo de oxígeno
tenemos dos átomos de hidrógeno cierto y
esa es la misma proporción de oxígeno e
hidrógeno que tiene el agua y bueno
claramente aquí no es que tengamos un
oxígeno y dos hidrógenos tenemos 6
oxígenos y 12 hidrógenos pero bueno
además nos tenemos que familiarizar con
cuáles son todas las partes de la
glucosa porque hay por ejemplo aquí en
el carbono 1 tenemos un grupo carbón y
lo ok cuando tenemos un carbono
con un doble enlace a un oxígeno eso es
un grupo carbón y lo grupo carbón y lo
ahora este carbono tiene otros dos
enlaces y como uno de esos enlaces es a
una cadena de carbonos y el otro enlace
es a un hidrógeno entonces también es un
grupo aldehído grupo aldehído y eso hace
que toda esta molécula sea un aldehído
ok si una molécula contiene un grupo
aldehído esa molécula es un aldehído así
es que la glucosa cuando es dibujada en
esta forma de cadena recta o bueno
cuando está en su forma de cadena la
glucosa es una leído y bueno además
tiene todos estos otros grupos ibrox y
los que todos estos otros grupos hidroxi
los de hecho hacen que la glucosa sea un
alcohol y también es importante poner
atención en cuál
esta estructura aquí tenemos 6 carbonos
el primer carbono es parte de este grupo
aldehído o bueno también parte de un
grupo carbon hilo y luego los otros 5
carbonos cada uno tiene un enlace con un
grupo hidroxilo y cuando tenemos la
glucosa orientada de esta forma cuatro
de esos grupos hidroxilo se están hacia
la derecha pero el tercer carbono su
grupo hidroxilo está hacia la izquierda
y luego el resto de los enlaces de los
carbonos es con hidrógenos ok al carbono
le gusta hacer cuatro enlaces covalentes
cada uno de estos carbonos tiene cuatro
enlaces covalentes entonces una vez que
ya estamos tomando en cuenta los enlaces
entre estos carbonos los enlaces con los
grupos hidroxilo sss y este doble enlace
del grupo carbón y lo el resto de los
enlaces que forman los carbonos van a
ser enlaces covalentes con hidrógenos
ahora
esto es cuando tenemos a la glucosa en
su forma de cadena recta pero también
podemos tener la glucosa en su forma
cíclica y es muy interesante pensar en
cómo pasamos de esta forma a esta otra
ok y lo que yo hice fue volver a dibujar
esta cadena por aquí pero doblando la un
poquito ahora para ver que realmente son
la misma cadena podemos empezar por
volver a numerar estos carbonos ok
este es el carbono del grupo carbón y lo
así es que es el carbono 1 y después de
ahí nos seguimos entonces este es el
carbono 2 3 4 5 y 6 la razón por la que
dice que este enlace fuera un poquito
más gordo es como para denotar que este
enlace es el más cercano a nosotros
porque como que se está saliendo de la
pantalla hacia nosotros y luego conforme
pasamos del carbono 2 al carbono 1 en
este enlace nos estamos volviendo
a meter a la pantalla y lo mismo sucede
en el enlace del carbono 3 al carbono 4
nos estamos volviendo a meter hacia la
pantalla y bueno este enlace entre el
carbono 3 y el carbono 2 aquí está el
carbono 3 del carbono 2 es este enlace
de aquí
y este enlace es este enlace de aquí y
finalmente este enlace es este enlace de
acá acercándonos hacia la pantalla y
ahora ponle pausa el vídeo si lo
necesitas para orientar estas dos
moléculas lo que hicimos fue tomar esta
parte de la molécula y girarla hacia acá
hasta llegar por aquí
y luego tomar esta parte de la molécula
y girarla hacia acá hasta llegar por acá
y además doblamos la cadena un poco como
para que el carbono 6 este por aquí y
ahora porque estamos haciendo esto bueno
pues porque la forma cíclica es la forma
en la que más nos vamos a encontrar a la
glucosa aunque hay generalmente este
grupo hidroxilo reacciona y hace que la
glucosa tenga esta forma aunque también
hay algunas otras formas de la glucosa
este grupo hidroxilo del carbono 5 puede
llegar y atacar al carbono 1 que se
encuentra en este grupo carbón hilo
porque pues ya hemos hablado bastante al
respecto pero el oxígeno es muy electro
negativo y le encanta abrazar a los
electrones así es que este carbono uno
tiene una carga parcial positiva y
entonces por aquí en este grupo
hidroxilo este oxígeno tiene dos pares
de electrones libres y entonces el
oxígeno puede llegar y formar un enlace
con este carbono si estuviéramos en
química orgánica a esto le llamaríamos
un ataque núcleo físico que suena muy
elegante pero que básicamente nada más
quiere decir que aquí tenemos un carbono
que tiene una carga parcial positiva
aquí este oxígeno tiene un par de
electrones libres que puede utilizar
para formar un enlace
y cuando se forma este enlace obtenemos
esta molécula de aquí
y ese enlace es este de aquí y luego
pues este carbono puede soltar los
electrones de alguno de estos dos
enlaces del enlace doble
y el oxígeno entonces puede tener una
carga parcial negativa o puede usar esos
electrones para quedarse con algún
protón de hidrógeno que se encuentra en
la solución probablemente en alguna
molécula de hidrógeno que vamos a
dibujarlo de esta forma estos electrones
se están usando para formar un enlace
con este protón de hidrógeno que por
cierto este protón de hidrógeno no tiene
electrones es simplemente un protón ok
es el núcleo del hidrógeno sin los
electrones es unión del hidrógeno así es
que estos electrones ahora están
formando este enlace
ahora para que quede muy claro este
carbono de aquí es justo este carbono de
aquí
y este oxígeno es este oxígeno de acá y
listo ya tenemos aquí nuestro ciclo
claro que en estos momentos me puedes
preguntar oye pero que no se supone que
aquí tenemos un hidrógeno por cómo lo
hemos dibujado aquí parecería que
tenemos un hidrógeno y que este oxígeno
tiene una carga positiva pero hoy
estamos en una solución de agua y cómo
te puedes imaginar tenemos por aquí otra
molécula de agua y todas las moléculas
están interactuando unas con otras
bueno de hecho vamos a dibujar al
oxígeno del color adecuado tiene que sus
dos pares de electrones libres y este
oxígeno tiene una carga positiva por el
momento y entonces puede llegar una
molécula de agua y llevarse únicamente
al protón de este hidrógeno permitiendo
que los electrones de este enlace se
queden con el oxígeno
esta molécula de agua se lleva
únicamente un protón y entonces estos
electrones del enlace se quedan con el
oxígeno y ahora si ya es un oxígeno
neutro tal cual como lo tenemos aquí ok
y por aquí es cierto esta molécula de
agua se quedó con únicamente un protón
más ahora es una molécula de hidrógeno
pero eso no está mal porque por aquí
tomamos únicamente un protón ok le dimos
un protón a la solución pero también
tomamos un protón de la solución así es
que estamos a mano y podemos terminar
con esta molécula
la razón por la que hicimos todo esto es
para que cuando te encuentres esto en tu
clase de biología o en tu clase de
química no te sientas intimidado de
hecho es súper valioso estar
familiarizado con este tipo de
estructuras porque pues te vas a
encontrar muchísimas veces con la
glucosa te vas a encontrar con muchos
azúcares y con muchísimos muchísimos
otros tipos de moléculas a lo largo de
tu carrera académica